- Yo, Will.
- Yo.
My fault I ain't call
you back, man,
it's been a crazy ass day.
Your mom told me you got
sprung out of jail,
but she won’t say
where you at.
You’re still in Philly, right?
Nah, bro, I’m in L.A.
L.A.?
Man, stop cappin’, yo.
No cap!  Man, this shit
happened so quick!
Bro, Rashad’s gotta
bag on your head, bro.
He’s saying you snitched
to get out.
What?
No one snitched on nobody.
Then how you get
out of jail then?
My uncle pulled
some crazy lawyer shit.
That's all I know.
Rashad wants you dead, bro.
I think I'm next.
You gotta come back and
clear this shit up, like, ASAP.
Just be cool, aight?
Be cool, and lay low.  Aight?
I’m scared.
I’m coming.  I’mma fix this.
Aight, bro.
What the hell is this
Jackie Chan, Splinter Cell shit?
Shit!
Yo Jazz, man, I've got to
get to LAX, man.
I gotta catch a midnight
flight to Philly.
Wait, you didn't kill or rob
nobody in that mansion, did you?
‘Cause I ain’t tryna
catch a case, Will.
Nah man, everybody in the
mansion is good,
I just got to get back home
ASAP, aight?
Come on, let’s go!
But you're already home, Will.
Shit.
Turn it off.
Well, who are you?
Phillip Banks,
Will's Uncle.
Who the hell are you?
Uh... Jazz...
What up?
Jazz.
Thank you for your time, Jazz.
Thank you for your money, Phil.
Let's go back inside, Will.
I guess you missed
the 20 cameras
surrounding the property.
By the way,
what was the plan here?
So you go to LAX
and then what?  Hmm?
Fly home and
fix my situation.
Hmm.
What about that gangster
you pulled a gun on?
I mean I find it hard to believe
he’d just let that go.
What was your plan there?
Let me ask you something, Will.
You care if you live or die?
Yeah.
Me too.
So does your Mom, your Aunt,
and everyone in this house.
I can handle mine.
I ain’t never had no Daddy.
I’ve been my own man.
A real man takes the
time to consider
the consequences
of his actions.
A real man knows
when to let go of his pride
and make the most out
of his second chance.
A real man also knows
how to look another man
in the eye when saying
something.  Look at me.
I believe in you, Will.
Be patient.
Give this a real chance,
and I promise...
that you’ll have
every opportunity
to create the future you want.
You have my word.
Do we have a deal?
Good.